à marseille au procès des quatre jeunes
auteurs de la profanation du cimetière
juif de carpentras suite des débats
aujourd'hui avec notamment la déposition
du rabbin sitruk et cet après-midi
l'exposé des faits par les accusés
eux-mêmes dominique verdeilhan valérie
hier le juge sylvie meute n'a jamais
accepté d'être dessaisi du dossier
elle a dû faire face aux rumeurs aux
manipulations aux pressions médiatiques
toutes les pistes ont été vérifiés du
talent il n'était pas question pour moi
de fermer le dossier
mais à la barre sylvie mode se retient
pour ce magistrat visiblement blessé ce
n'est ni le lieu ni l'heure des
règlements de compte
le procès est ailleurs quand les caps
prévenu mal à l'aise détail la
profanation
on passe de l'horreur à l'immonde
exhumation simulacre d'emballement
tentative de décapitation cette nuit là
ils n'ont éprouvé qu'une seule répulsion
l'odeur du cadavre courageuse digne
madame germond apostrophe les quatre
prévenus vous êtes des criminels vous
m'avez tué je vais souffrir jusqu'à ma
mort si au moins vous pouviez me dire
pourquoi sol garnier celui qui a avoué
se lève
je regrette tout ce que j'ai fait
c'était de l'antisémitisme je voulais
vous demander pardon
ça m'a fait du bien c'est les voir et de
lui parler et m'a bien regarder il a
compris pourquoi il a fait ça je lui ai
demandé pourquoi alors ce soir résonnent
encore les mots du grand rabbin joseph
sitruk ils n'ont tué personne
ils ont tué tout le monde le pardon ne
sera effectif que lorsqu'ils auront
compris ce qu'ils ont fait mais ce soir
force est de constater que pour trois
des profanateurs le mot pardon
n'appartient pas à leur vocabulaire